>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Please give a warm
welcome to Michael Buckley.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Buckley: Hey.
>> Hey.
>> Michael Buckley: Where
is my beanbag chair?
[laughter] This is not cool.
Thanks. My name is Mike.
Thank you so much for coming
out here on a rainy day and also
for sticking around until the end
for the very part of it, me, yay.
[ Applause ]
You guys are so lucky.
My name is Mike, and I have
written a bunch of books.
One of them is called
The Sisters Grimm,
and I wrote a series called
Nerds, and I wrote a book
for teenagers called Undertow,
and I wrote a book for little,
little kids called Kel
Gilligan's Daredevil Stunt Show.
And I might tell you a
little bit about those books,
but first I thought I might tell
you about how I became an author.
Does anyone here want to
know how I became an author?
It's a very exciting
story, it has ninjas in it.
[laughter] It doesn't,
I'm just kidding.
I just want you guys to like me.
Like she said, I was born in
a town called Akron, Ohio.
Has anyone here ever
been to Akron, Ohio?
It is the most boring
place in the whole world.
The only exciting thing that ever
happened there is we invented
the zipper.
Yeah, that's huge, it's huge.
We also have a race there called the
Soapbox Derby, and this is a race
where we take a small
child, put them in a box
and shove them down a steep hill.
[laughter] So Akron
is fun on that day.
Now when I was 16 something
really exciting happened to me,
I was reading a magazine
called Mad Magazine.
Has anyone here ever
heard of Mad Magazine?
If you don't know that
magazine ask your parents.
It's a very silly magazine,
lots of jokes.
In the back of the magazine
there was a contest,
it was a joke writing contest and
they promised a very big prize.
And I thought I'd like
a very big prize.
So I decided to write a
joke and I mailed it in,
and about two months
later I got a letter back
and they told me I
had won the prize.
Would you guys like
to hear the joke?
>> Yes.
>> Michael Buckley: All right, why
did the monkey fall out of the tree?
Because it was dead.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know, and I won the contest.
No one else saw the ad, I guess.
But I did win the contest and I got
-- I did get a really big prize,
but it didn't come in a box, it came
on a plane because it was a person.
They actually sent me a very
funny person to hang out with
for a whole day and his
name was Eddie Murphy.
Now you guys might know Eddie,
he's the donkey in Shrek
and he's the dragon in Mulan,
and he's the dad in a lot
of very embarrassing movies.
And he's in a lot of movies, I'm
hoping your parents are good enough
to never have let you see.
But when I was a kid he was on a
show called Saturday Night Live
and I was a very big fan.
So Eddie came to Akron, like I
said, and we hung out the whole day,
but we were in Akron so
there was nothing to do.
So we went to the mall and we
made fun of people all day long.
[laughter] It was the best day ever.
And then we went to the Olive Garden
and we had spaghetti and meatballs.
And Eddie looked at me and he said,
you know, you're pretty funny,
you know when I was 16 I
started doing standup comedy
in New York City, maybe
you should do that, too.
And I thought, that
sounds interesting.
So when Eddie went back to
New York City I went to all
of the comedy clubs in
Akron, which was one.
And I said I want to be a comedian,
and they said, son, how old are you,
you've got to be 18
to be a comedian?
And I thought about
my mom and my grandma
and how they'd always
told me never to lie,
never to tell a fib,
especially to an adult.
So I looked at the man and I
said I'm 18, and he believed it.
Because I think it's
okay to lie to people
if they're too dumb
to know the truth.
[laughter] That's not a very
nice thing, don't repeat that.
I give bad advice.
I'm not a very good role
model for children or adults.
So I started doing standup, and
this is where I learned how to write
because a joke is a lot like a
little story, there's a set-up
like a premise to the joke, and
then there's a rising tension
where you don't know
what's going to happen,
and then if you've written a good
joke there's a surprise twist
ending, just like in a story.
And that is when I began
to understand books I
think a little bit more.
So I started writing my own jokes
and I performed all over the country
with a bunch of comedians that
hopefully you have never heard
of because they are naughty.
And then I went to college
and I studied writing,
and I did some other things.
I was in a punk rock band,
I had really long hair,
it went down to here.
I was hot, yeah.
[laughter] I was.
Afterwards I went to --
I graduated from college,
I went to a place called New York
City, maybe you've heard of it.
And I was an intern on a
television show called The Late Show
with David Letterman, and I was
one of David Letterman's interns.
Now if you've never seen that
show it was a talk show and lots
of famous people came on all the
time, lots of glamorous people,
like the first day I was
there I got to meet Beyonce.
She's pretty.
And then the next day
I met George Clooney.
He's pretty, too.
[laughter] But my job
was not very glamorous.
One of the things I had to
do on the show was take care
of David Letterman's dog.
Dave brought his big Golden
Retriever to work every day.
And Golden Retrievers are usually
happy animals, but not Dave's.
Dave's dog was a big fat
yellow meatball of rage.
It would bite me, it would bite
old people, it would bite children,
it would bite trees,
it would bite itself.
[laughter] You know you're
angry if you bite yourself.
But every once in awhile
if I wasn't being murdered
by that dog they would let
me write a joke for the show,
and I would write my joke on a
piece of paper and I'd hand it
to David Letterman and
then I'd go up on the stage
and I'd hide behind the curtain
and I would watch the audience.
Now I had been telling jokes in
front of audiences for a long time
by then, but for some reason
this would make me very nervous
and I think it was because this
audience was really, really big.
Like we had about 500 people in the
studio audience, but we also had
about 10 million people watching at
home, so it would make me nervous
and I would hide behind the stage.
And I would hear Dave tell
the joke and I would look out
and I would see a reaction
come over people.
If it got a big laugh their
eyes would get really big
and their mouths would open and
their faces would turn pink,
and they would rock back and forth
in their chairs, and they'd go, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ah, oh,
that hurt, oh, oh, ow,
ooh, I wet myself, I'm sorry.
[laughter] And I would look out
there and I'd go, I did that,
I made those people do that,
I'm funny joke writer man.
The worst superhero ever, but
it still felt really cool.
I think that was the first time
when I truly understood the power
of words and what you
can do with them.
If you write the right words
you can change somebody's mood,
and if you write the really right
words you can change somebody's day,
and if you write the
really, really, really,
really right words you might be able
to change somebody's whole life.
And, to me, that sounded
like a pretty good job.
And that's what I've been
doing now for about 13 years.
The first book I ever wrote is this
one, it's called The Sisters Grimm.
Has anybody read this book?
The cool people in the
audience, all right,
thank you very much,
I appreciate it.
Thank you for the royalty check.
A few years ago our publisher
came to me and said, you know,
this book is still really
popular, we're thinking
about doing a tenth
anniversary edition.
And that's what I've got in my hand,
this is the tenth anniversary
edition.
It has all new art, it
has a brand-new design,
and it has new words because I
decided to rewrite every single one.
And I'll read a little
bit of it for you.
They told me not to read to
you guys, did you hear that?
I'm not supposed to do this.
You guys feel brave?
I don't want the police
coming in here.
You guys are going to have
to stop them if they charge.
They're after everybody
now, nurses, who knows?
[laughter] The parents know
what I'm talking about.
All right, some of these
jokes are just for me, folks.
In the distance a thunderous
bellow rang out,
followed by the terrible
sound of falling trees
and a stampede of terrified animals.
It was coming and there
was no way to outrun it.
Still Sabrina and Daphne had to try.
They sprinted as fast as they could,
fighting with every step
the dense forest branches
that snatched at their
faces and arms.
We have to find a way to stop
it, Daphne cried between gasps.
Sabrina knew her little
sister was right, but how?
They were two children
versus a vicious monster.
I'll think of something, she said,
dragging her sister
behind an enormous oak tree
for a much needed rest.
Sabrina squeezed Daphne's hand to
reassure her while she forced air
into her own burning lungs.
Her words sounded empty in her ears.
She didn't have a plan, and even
if she did it wouldn't
make a difference.
The creature was on top
of them, splintering wood
and damp soil rained from the sky
as the tree they crouched
behind was violently uprooted.
The two girls looked up into
the horrible face above them
and felt scorching breath
blow through their hair.
What was happening to their lives?
Sabrina wondered, when did the
world become unrecognizable
and what had happened to
her, the 11-year-old girl
who had only two days prior
had been an orphan on a train?
Bum, bum, bum.
Now you're all like
what was that about?
Because I should have
told you that before,
but I'm going to tell you now.
The Sisters Grimm is about these
two girls who move to a town
where everyone is a
fairytale character,
like Prince Charming is the Mayor,
and the Three Little Pigs
run the Police Department,
and the Big Bad Wolf
is the yoga instructor.
[laughter] And they discovered that
all the fairytales that we read
to our children aren't really
stories, but they're case files
because the people who wrote
them were a couple of guys known
as The Brothers Grimm and
they were actually detectives.
And all these stories we've
been reading are real stories.
And the girls encounter a bunch of
these stories throughout nine books.
They meet characters from The
Wizard of Oz and Rumpelstiltskin
and Snow White, and they
meet The Little Mermaid,
and pretty much anything you could
ever imagine, Robin Hood, Pinocchio.
I just crammed them all in there
because they're public
domain and no one can sue me.
So does anybody have any
questions about the book?
We have some microphones here
and if you have a question
I would love to hear it.
If you do not ask questions
I have been known
to ask you deeply personal
ones, let that motivate you.
Okay, all right, sir,
tell us your name?
>> Finn.
>> Michael Buckley: Finn,
that's my son's name.
All right, that's lucky.
I'm going to take that as lucky.
>> Why did you create
The Sisters Grimm?
>> Michael Buckley: Oh, there's
money in children's books.
[laughter]
>> Are you kidding me?
>> Michael Buckley: No.
You know, there's two reasons why.
I was reading a book
about the Brothers Grimm,
whose names were Jacob and
Wilhelm, and I discovered
that the brothers had
actually came from a big family
and that they had sisters.
And I couldn't really stop
thinking about what those sisters,
what it must have been like to
have such creepy older brothers.
And then I went to a bookstore
just to see what was out there
and like there's lots
of children's books now,
but at the time there
really weren't that many
and I discovered this fact, there
are two kinds of children's books.
There's books for boys where
the boy rides a dragon or goes
to wizarding school or fights
monsters, and then there's books
for girls where the girl
takes care of a pony.
[laughter] And I thought that was
lame because I didn't know any women
in my life who would take
a pony over a dragon ride.
So I decided to write
the book for that.
[applause] Yes, thank you.
He's so woke, yeah.
All right, who is next?
>> What was your favorite
book in the series?
>> Michael Buckley: Oh, I loved
them all, they're like my children.
Does your mother ever tell you that
she loves you children all the same?
>> Yes.
>> Michael Buckley: She's lying.
[laughter] She has a favorite,
but it's not good for you to know,
even if you're the favorite.
It might even be worse
for you to know that.
You know, I think that my
favorite one was the fifth one,
it's called Magic and
Other Misdemeanors.
My favorite movie of all
time is Back to the Future,
and I wanted to write
a time travel story.
So the girls get to go into the
future and see how they turn
out when they're in their 20s and
they do not like it so they have
to go back and change the past
so the future never happens.
And I had a great time
writing that one, yes,
that's probably my favorite one.
>> Back to the Future
is a good movie.
>> Michael Buckley: I
agree, even the sequels,
and that's how much I like it.
Yes?
>> Hello. I just wanted to say
that I read The Sisters
Grimm in elementary school.
>> Michael Buckley:
Don't tell me that.
How old are you?
>> I'm 16.
>> Michael Buckley: Ah, that
means I'm getting older, too.
>> But I love those books so much.
>> Michael Buckley: Thank you.
>> And they really inspired me, like
the stories and the sisters and how
like -- they were really good.
I loved them.
So thank you for that.
>> Michael Buckley: Ah, thanks.
>> What was your inspiration for
the sisters, Daphne and Sabrina?
>> Michael Buckley: There's a few,
but I would say before I met my
wife I had a girlfriend named Renee
and she had an older
sister named Danielle,
and they looked a little bit
like the Sisters Grimm in a way.
They were -- they fought
like cats and dogs,
I mean they would literally
fistfight in front of me,
but if somebody else
were to like attack them
or insult them then they would team
up and beat that person up, too.
They were from New Jersey,
which explains a lot.
I'm sorry to New Jersey,
it's just a joke.
But, yeah, they were probably
the biggest inspirations, yeah.
>> Hi.
>> Michael Buckley: Hi.
>> I have two questions.
>> Michael Buckley: Okay.
>> How did you write your books?
Do you write them in chunks
or did you write them all
at once, well, one book?
>> Michael Buckley: Well, the
first book honestly was sort
of already there in my head
when I sat down to write it.
It was pretty simple, it
just kind of flew out.
But later on I began to realize
that I would change the method
of how I wrote, so that
sometimes if I was stuck
on one thing I would just
stop and move to a chapter
that I could see in my head.
I usually don't write anything
until I can actually see it.
It almost plays out like a movie
and then I just write
down what I'm seeing.
So now I tend to write
pretty linearly,
like the beginning to the end.
I've found that when I
skip too far ahead I wind
up not using the stuff
I wrote later.
But, yeah, it's sort of
all over the place, yeah.
That doesn't answer
any question, sorry.
>> Also, what time is it when
an elephant sits on a fence?
>> Michael Buckley:
Time to get a new fence.
>> That's correct.
[laughter]
>> Michael Buckley:
Professional comedian.
[applause]
>> Sorry for anyone who
hasn't read the books,
this includes a spoiler alert.
>> Michael Buckley: Oh, oh.
>> Have you ever thought
of writing a book
like after Sabrina has her
children and marries Puck?
>> Michael Buckley: Spoiler.
Boy, you just dropped a bomb.
No, that's okay, I think most people
probably could figure that out.
But, yeah, at the end of the
last book I wrote a little sort
of an epilogue where you see
Sabrina and she's in her early 40s
and she has two teenaged
daughters, Allison and Emma.
And at the end of the book
Allison screams and Sabrina runs
up the stairs to find
out what's wrong,
and Allison has grown fairy wings.
And I thought that it
would be interesting
to write maybe a few books about
a girl who is a fairy princess,
but lives in New York City
and doesn't really want
to be a fairy princess.
And maybe someday I'll write
that, but right now I'm kind of --
I'm busy writing a
different thing for kids,
so someday I'll probably
go back to it.
It does keep calling me, yeah.
>> Why did you use fairytale
characters for like adult jobs?
>> Michael Buckley: Well, one of the
things people always ask me is like,
you know, why are the characters so
different than how I remember them?
For instance, like Snow White
teaches self-defense classes
in the book, she has a
class called the Bad Apples
and she's very independent,
and that's not how you
remember the story.
But, you know, these characters have
been around for hundreds of years
and I'm not the same
person I was 10 years ago
and you won't be the same person
that you are now 10
years from today.
So people needed to
be able to change,
and I thought it would
be fun to see what kind
of jobs they would be doing.
So, you know, Snow White is
really good with little people
so she's a teacher and, you know,
the Three Little Pigs have had
so much trauma in their lives that
they decide to grow up and try
to rescue and be heroes for others,
which is usually the case of a lot
of people who do heroic jobs.
And then, you know, the
Scarecrow was a librarian
because he's got his brain now.
And some of them just
seemed pretty obvious,
like but then there was
the Witch from Hansel
and Gretel is now dentist.
And so there were some that I
had a really fun time coming
up with the jobs.
Yes?
>> What happened to their parents?
>> Michael Buckley: I
can't tell you that.
I won't sell any books today.
I will tell you that you discover
something happens with the parents
in the third book, I will say that.
Yes?
>> From the first time
you started writing
and drafting your book
how long did it take
for your first book
to get published?
>> Michael Buckley:
Oh, this is a story
that makes a lot of people angry.
[laughter] I didn't actually have
a book when I got it published.
I had about 30 pages and
a very loose outline.
I just got very lucky.
See, I'd been working in
television for a long time
and in TV what you do is you write
a little bit and then you try
to go get somebody
to pay you to finish.
So I did the same thing,
I thought, well,
I'm not going to give them
the whole book, you know,
I'm like let them pay
me to finish the book.
And my agent was like that's the
dumbest thing I have ever heard.
And I said let's just try it.
And so she sent it out and we had
three offers within like two weeks.
And the editor who actually signed
the book said the reason she read it
in the first place is that
she knew she could finish it
on the subway on the way home.
And so that's basically how
I've done it ever since,
I just give them a little bit
and then say you want
to know how it ends?
You got to write me a check.
[laughter] Yes?
>> Who is your favorite character?
>> Michael Buckley: Oh,
my favorite character?
Oh, well, it changes so
much, but I would say
that the character I have grown to
love was the one I didn't even want
to use in the first place,
which was Prince Charming.
I just thought this was a
character I had seen way too much,
but he was so interesting to me
and he surprised me all the time.
And he's sort of a reluctant
hero, maybe like a rusty hero,
somebody who has decided to
take care of himself now more
than look out for other people.
And the book series is really as
much about him as it is anybody,
it's his journey back
to being a good person.
And so I think Prince
Charming turned
out to be the one I loved the most.
Yes?
>> I have two questions.
>> Michael Buckley: Okay.
>> First, have you ever thought
about a Sisters Grimm movie?
>> Michael Buckley: Yeah,
yeah, I've thought about it.
I'm not supposed to
tell anybody this,
but we actually signed a
deal like two weeks ago.
[applause] Shush, don't
tell anybody.
It's not going to be a movie,
it's going to be an animated
show on Amazon Prime.
So if you get Amazon don't
buy any books off of it,
but get Amazon Prime and then
you can watch it for free.
>> Also, they said
that, somebody said
that you wrote a TV show
for a cartoon network?
>> Michael Buckley: Uh-huh, it
was called Robotomy and it was
about two teenaged robots who
go to a high school on a planet
where everyone is a killer robot,
but they're the sensitive ones.
So they keep having to hide like
their love of poetry and bunnies
and it was -- don't let the
children watch this show,
it's super offensive.
But it was on Monday
nights, it was on right
after Adventure Time for a year.
And I just couldn't do it
anymore, it was so much work
and so we decided to stop doing it.
I might -- I don't actually have any
creative or like any real job title
on The Sisters Grimm cartoon, which
I have no problem with at all,
but I would like to do some
TV shows in the future.
But this one was just an
insane amount of work.
Yes?
>> First of all, my name is Sabrina.
>> Michael Buckley: Whoa.
>> And what is your favorite book?
>> Michael Buckley: My
favorite book of all time?
You know, it would
have to be the book
that I read in the fourth grade.
I was what they called, well, they
called them reluctant readers now,
back then they just called
us a pain in the butt.
[laughter] I didn't like to read
because there really weren't a lot
of kids' books out there and
the ones that there were were
like about a kid who
had to shoot a pet.
So I wasn't super excited about it.
There were like 400
books about children
with firearms, blowing a dog away.
I don't understand this theme,
it was very popular at one time.
Maybe dogs were different
back then, I don't know.
Mine is wonderful.
But I didn't really like to read,
and luckily I had a librarian notice
that I had never checked a
book out of the school library.
And she grabbed me and
dragged me into the library
and grabbed a book off the
shelf and shoved it in my hands
and told me I had to
read it and I had
to tell her all about
it in two weeks.
And that book was called The
Mouse and the Motorcycle,
and it's by Beverly Cleary.
If you've never read it, it's great,
especially if you're a little boy
because it has the three things
a little boy wants in a book.
It's a big adventure, it's funny,
and it's absolutely pointless.
I was not supposed to learn anything
from The Mouse on the Motorcycle.
I wasn't going to be a
better person afterwards.
But it was just a fun
sort of rainy day book,
and I thought after I finished
it it was like I wonder
if there are more like this?
And then she introduced me to
tons more of these silly books
that didn't have any
dead dogs in them.
And so I would say that's probably
still my favorite book, yeah.
Yes, ma'am?
>> How long have you been an author?
>> Michael Buckley: Well, I would
say it's like 12, 13 years now.
Before that I had a
bunch of different jobs.
Like I said, I worked in TV,
I worked for an advertising,
I used to work for a
company called Macy's.
And like if you've ever
bought like linen from Macy's,
my job was to write the tag, I
wrote the tag on the bed in the bag.
So I know more about thread
counts and the damask stripe
than any man ever should.
[laughter]
>> How did you get your inspiration
for all the characters in Nerds?
>> Michael Buckley: In Nerds?
He's asking about the
other series I write,
which is about nerdy secret
agents who are in the fifth grade
and each one of them has
kind of a nerdy superpower.
And those kids are based
on real kids that I knew.
There's a kid in the book, his name
is Duncan Dewey and he's inspired
by a kid that I knew
named Avery Dortch.
And in the book Duncan's code name
is glue stick because he can stick
to walls, and but the real Avery
Dortch used to do this thing,
he would take Elmer's Glue and
he would smear it on his hands
and then he'd walk through the
halls like this until it dried
and then he'd find a group of pretty
girls and he would peel it off
and eat it right in front of them.
Avery had a way with the ladies.
[laughter] So the kids are all
based on real people that I knew.
I'm not even sure Avery
is still alive.
I don't think you should
be eating paste
in the mass quantities that he did.
Don't eat the paste, kids.
Thank you.
I think we have time for
one more, how about you?
Sorry.
>> Have you written any joke books?
>> Michael Buckley: Oh,
no, you don't want that.
Publishing doesn't want that.
They will never bring me
back here if I do that.
But my son reads this book called
The Absolute Best Joke Book
in the World, and it's pretty
good evidence of how you can lie
as a title because these
are the worst jokes ever.
But my son does write, has written
a few that I think are funny,
and I'll tell you my favorite joke.
His jokes are very meta, they're
like really kind of surreal.
Here's one, it's like what do
you call a tiger wearing glasses?
Scientist tiger.
[laughter] He's only nine, so.
And then he's like why did
the taco cross the road?
Because there was an ATM over
there and he needed money.
[laughter] These are actual
jokes from Finn Buckley, yeah.
Guys, thank you so much for coming.
[applause] I'm going to be
doing a signing at six o'clock.
And while I still have
your attention I just want
to tell you this hurricane down
in Texas has really been terrible.
One of the things that Texas is
desperately going to need is books.
Schools, libraries were completely
decimated, water has gotten
into those buildings and
destroyed entire libraries.
If you have any extra books put
them in a box and find a place
to send them to in Houston.
And if you can't do that
I'd recommend that you go
on your old phone and you
send a text message to 909-99
and in the subject line
just type the word Harvey
and you can make a $10
donation to the Red Cross.
I think it's a good cause and I
hope you guys will check it out.
Thanks for spending
some time with me.
I'll see you at the signing
booth at six o'clock.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.